hello and welcome i am james murphy from
emcoding.io and today
we are recovering a problem that i've
covered in a previous video
the problem that we're covering again is
the first missing integer problem
last time i covered this problem i
solved it using python and
i took advantage of one of the problem
constraints
that the input array size is at most 300
and because i really took advantage of
that constraint the solution that i came
up with
wouldn't really work if you had much
bigger array sizes so today i'm redoing
it in c plus plus
and i'm going to be using an algorithm
that will work
for whatever array size you want so just
to recap the problem we're given an
input array like this 3 4 minus 1 1
5 and we're supposed to find the
smallest positive integer
that is not in the list so in this case
we have 1
is there but 2 isn't so the algorithm
should return
2. the way that i'm solving it this time
is going to be a lot better than last
time because
i'm not going to use extra space that
depends on the size of the nums array so
this algorithm will work no matter how
big nums is
additionally it's going to scan through
the array at most twice so here's the
idea
for each slot in the array imagine the
number that should be there
so in this case first we see a three and
the 3 is supposed to go here so let's
put a 3 here
now we clobbered this value -1 in order
to put the 3 there
but minus 1 is outside of the range of
numbers that we care about
so during this algorithm whenever we
encounter a number that's outside the
range that we care about
we just ignore it or we stop what we're
doing
and move on to the next iteration okay
so the next iteration
we go through and we see four four is
supposed to go here
so we put four there
now we had to displace one in order to
put the four there and we do care about
one
so let's continue the process with the
one
one is supposed to go in this location
so let's put it there
and we had to displace a three in order
to do that
so we go to where 3 should be and we see
that 3 is already there so we stop then
we continue on to the next iteration
which is here we see a 3 which is
already in the right place so we move on
we see a four already in the right place
so we move on
we see a five already in the right place
so we move on and then we hit the end of
the array
we're done with the first pass notice
now that any element in the array that
we care about
is in the correct position so all we
have to do is scan through the array
and see if the number that we find at
that position is the correct number
we look at the first position and we see
a one that's correct so we move on
then we look at the second position and
we see a four but we're supposed to see
a 2.
if there was a 2 in this array it would
have moved to this position
so there must not be a 2 in the array so
we can stop
and return 2 as the answer this is an
amazingly simple and fast algorithm that
gets the job done
so let's switch over to vs code and code
the solution
so first we just make a loop over the
array if you're wondering why i'm using
longs here the problem statement says
that the ins that are in this vector
can be all the way up to the maximum
possible end to the minimum possible end
and so since we're going to be doing
plus or minus 1 kind of things
i went ahead and made these longs in
order to avoid overflow issues
next we just check for the current
element that we're looking at
is the index of valid index so current
minus one
is the index that current should go in
since we're only looking for positive
integers and not non-negative integers
the index corresponding to current is
just current minus one
this checks to see if current minus one
is a valid index
and then this checks to see whether we
have looped back on ourselves
so if current were equal to next then
there's nothing more to do
then inside this while loop all we do is
put current
into the location that it's supposed to
go and then uh replace it with next
after this for loop all of the positive
integers that were in the vector are now
in the right places
then we just loop through the vector
again and look for the first index for
which
uh the thing at that index is not equal
to what's supposed to be there
of course it's possible that we never
return from this return statement
everything is in its rightful place so
the first missing thing
is the first thing that's outside of the
range
so that would be the length of the
vector plus one all right so i went
ahead and submitted it
uh it says the run time was zero
milliseconds faster than 100
of c plus online submissions for this
problem
so i can't imagine that no one else has
come up with this solution
and that this is actually the fastest
code that has ever been run for this
question
i'm guessing just that anything less
than one millisecond
is deemed zero milliseconds and so a
whole bunch of good answers get lumped
as exactly 100 so there you have it
there's my second take at the first
missing in problem with a much better
solution i hope you enjoyed this one a
lot more than the last one
and if you did don't forget to like
comment and subscribe see in the next
one